hello everyone josh and i
well we'd like to give you something for
free that's right we got a brand new
book coming out it's called love people
use things it comes out july 13th but if
you pre-order it by june 1st
you get the free love people companion
workbook
head on over to lovepeopleusethings.net
to find all the details this episode of
the minimalist is brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua phillips-milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists you know ryan many
of us are tired of allowing other people
to have dominion
over our income and our creative
outcomes
a lot of people ask us about working for
self and
how do you guys make money right and so
a lot of you make money maybe you'll
explain that to me one day we'll reveal
all of our secrets this week on the
patreon episode i thought you're going
to say something like turn your dominion
into minions
[Laughter]
well you know what how did we make money
we took back control of our own lives
a decade ago and um today we're really
going to talk about
how we make a living on our own and how
you can as well whether you're an
aspiring creator
a small business owner an artist or an
entrepreneur
and who better to talk about that with
than the founder of patreon himself
jack conte is here yeah jack all right
thanks so much for being here man thanks
for having me guys this is fun i'm
pumped for this
so we start the podcast with
advertisements suck that's been our
ethos for
over a decade now right why do they suck
what sucks about advertising oh man
we don't have enough time but i'll try
to i'll give you the yeah
we've written it pretty extensively
about this i will tell you this
um i think that they are the biggest
problem in our culture today they create
division they create the need for
us to um well
we are interrupted by four to ten
thousand advertisements a day now you
can argue as to whether or not all of
those are actually advertisements some
of them might be promotions but
regardless
all of our decisions are sort of
dictated by someone else
the expectations the needs the desires
of the culture of society
are being thrust upon us and and they're
creating these sort of false desires
everywhere
the reason we're over consuming so much
to a large extent has to do with
all of the things that are being thrust
upon us the products and services
and now all your favorite podcasts they
have you know 17 minutes of
advertisements before you even start
talking
we have none of that and one of the
reasons we don't have that
is well we wouldn't have ads either way
but the reason we could pay sean and
jordan and jessica and the other people
on our team
is because of what we do with patreon so
thank you heck yeah that's
really exciting and that's like the
purpose of the freaking company so it is
so cool to hear that awesome well and
we're going to talk about you know is
patreon right for everyone
we'll get into that now every week what
we do is we do a minimal episode a
maximal
episode so this is the minimal episode
right now so every tuesday we put a
minimal episode it's usually half hour
45 minutes
and we answer folks questions it's a
listener driven show we'll get into some
of those questions here in a moment
and then we do a maximal episode that's
every thursday on patreon
and that's the place we're really able
to let our hair down we talk about some
things we don't necessarily discuss
in public so it also provides us this
sort of semi-public
semi-private forum in a way where
we have these discussions that it's
almost like first drafts or like when a
stand-up comic
goes up on stage and they're trying out
new material
we do that in a way and it's it's just
more raw
and we have a smaller audience over
there six or seven thousand people
over on patreon and then it's you know
it's hundreds of thousands who listen to
the
the actual main podcast and so it's a
small portion that listens to us on
patreon
now um also my wife and i we we
have a podcast called how to love and we
started it initially as a patreon only
uh podcast we have since opened up a
public feed as well
and i i realized that there's a bit of a
balance
there and i want to talk to you about
that today before we get into the
questions though
why did you start patreon i'll give you
the
the two minute version rather than the
10 minute version
but the the two minute version is um so
i've been a creator
for the last decade and a half i guess
as soon as i finish college
i've started my my career as a creator
um
started a band with my wife called
pamplemoose we were
early musicians on on the youtubes and
did the whole music thing
still doing actually we still put out a
new music video every week with pompous
one came out this morning
um so you know i'm i'm releasing 50
music videos a year through pompous and
another 50 through my other band but
anyway
so started with papa moose started
cranking it doing it going on tour you
know doing the whole thing
um and then i got really deep into a
music video that i was making for my
solo
stuff on my solo channel it involved 3d
printed hexapod robots an animatronic
head that was singing the lyrics to the
song
i built a rapper club of a millennium
falcon cockpit behind me like
balls to the wall all out you know
full-blown creativity
um and lots and lots of work i ended up
spending three months of my life
on this music video cost me 10 grand
maxed out two credit cards
got to the end of this process thought
i'm gonna upload this video
to youtube it's gonna get about a
million
views because so many videos ago when i
upload them and i'm gonna check my ad
revenue the next
day and i'm gonna make 150 bucks
for this video sure and like after
three months of like pouring myself
into this video and just
you know i had a vision i realized it i
executed like i felt like i did my job
as an artist you know this is 2013
20 yeah end of 2012. like i felt like i
really
did what what what artists should be
doing you know
like i made the i made my dream yeah
and the thought of making that dream and
then reaching a million people with it
like not like oh i made my dream and i
put it out there and nobody liked it
like
i made my dream and a million people
loved it yes
i was like that's awesome and then to
get paid 150 bucks that was like
this this equation currently
in the web this equation that artists
are using where they put
art in yes and then things happen
between advertisers and consumers and
platforms and blah blah
and then it outputs a hundred and fifty
dollars to me that equip
can i swear i don't know that equation
[ __ ] sucks
it's broken it doesn't work it doesn't
make sense it's inefficient
it's a poor machine to drive the the
global productivity and creativity that
we're starting to see now with this
emerging creative class on the web that
whole equation needed to be fixed
and so the idea behind patreon is like
you know who likes my stuff
more than advertisers who like think of
me as a quote-unquote influencer right
that's what i am to an advertiser i am
influence
i'm a commodity like they've extracted
everything
away from me that makes me me and
they've just
left influence and that's their word for
me it was like we've taken away
everything about your personality
and we just want to purchase your
influence and we can get it from you or
we can get it from that person or we can
get it from that person and it's steel
to us it's corn
it's a commodity right so so you know
essentially what what uh what patreon
does is no
you know who likes my stuff more than
advertisers my fans
like the people who actually get
day-to-day value
from my stuff they care about me more
they care about me with their brains
with their hearts with their wallets
and um and that's a much better system
like consumer payments
is a much better system much more
efficient it ends up sending way more
value to creators right and to your
point there's a really interesting
benefit on the
on the fan side which is like you get to
be a part of this behind the scenes
thing where creators are sharing a
little bit more than they might normally
share
they're seeing you know glimpses of like
what it's like to be that creator
they're they're um getting exposed to
drafts
and like early ideas um
so that's kind of that's kind of the why
behind patreon is like this
system sucks we gotta fix it and
uh and then i yeah i called up my
freshman year roommate who was like an
engineer and he built the whole thing by
himself in two and a half months
wow and uh and we launched a couple
months later and
within like two weeks i was making six
figures as an artist
like wow two weeks i was the first
creator on patreon
and it was like it was like that
suddenly like it was fixed i didn't
change my music i changed my lyrics
i didn't i didn't wear different clothes
i didn't
sell out to advertisers i didn't i
didn't all i did was put up a patreon
page right and suddenly i was like
killing it as an artist and we're on the
maximum episode this week i want to get
into some details about who
patreon is appropriate for because it
may not be appropriate for everyone
and and i think i think that should be
clear but also
a lot of folks have questions about
making that leap because there's
there's a lot of people are intimidated
and so you you've actually
highlighted a few of the flaws here like
one is
the fact that you have to be reliant on
advertisers in the first place
so not only do you are you relying on
them but then your art is sullied by
well a tied ad so our youtube video if
you're watching us on youtube there's no
ads on our youtube either like
it's just i'm not judging someone else
who decides to go
that route but i've decided ryan has
decided it's not appropriate for us we
don't want to be beholden
to anyone but even then if you get a
million views and you're telling me you
make 150 bucks off of that it's crazy
and people are watching ads throughout
your throughout your art
yeah you imagine it's like a lose-lose
lose situation
except for the advertisers they win
they're the ones who wins yeah
but what i love about patreon is like
you've given a place
for fans to contribute to their favorite
artists
where before you know people will come
to us and they're like we love your work
um you know i bought some books i'm not
going to read them i'm just going to
give them away
i just wanted to find a way to support
you and so we started like i don't know
like a paypal you know donation button
or something
um which which was okay but the patreon
uh platform is just it's a beautiful way
for fans to really support their
favorite artist because when you add
value to
someone's life like people want to find
a way
for you to keep adding value it's so
true i i
have i don't know at this point maybe
130 140 subscriptions on youtube i don't
like
keep up with everybody 100 but like over
the years i've
formed a lot of fan relationships with
people on youtube
and like i don't like these people
i love them in a weird way right like i
i trust these people i
want them to be successful right i care
about them
yes i think about them it's a stray it's
a strange
thing right it's like we live in such a
strange age and you know i have no
delusions like i know i'm not friends
with these people
i know they're not my friends i know
that they're talking to matt right as
there's no
delusions there but it's a form of
intimacy
yes and that's real and its impact on my
life
is real yeah right like these people
help me make better decisions
yeah they help me evaluate my life and
my options
they they help me think about my
relationships like these are
important influential people in my life
yeah
and i want them to be very successful
like you know it's like if you ask me
like and then there's people whose art i
just love like if you ask me jack what
would you pay for another skrillex
record
like what's the upper threshold i don't
know that there is one i haven't done
that thought exercise but it's probably
very hot yeah yeah
you're willing to support skrillex
because you want another album yeah yeah
you like that wu-tang album where there
was just one coffee
oh but that jerk yesterday oh yeah right
the pharmaceutical guy
yeah that feels really weird right
because yeah that's bizarre
yeah yeah so we don't want that and what
i've what i've realized here is
it's not a donation either patreon is
yeah we provide a service to our patrons
and they actually get far more behind
that you know we can call it a paywall
that almost sounds pejorative at this
point but like
by signing up for a service like that or
guess what if you can't afford it if you
decide you don't want to go there
that's fine we we add a lot of value for
free
still ad free and the people who do
support the work
they're actually supplementing in a way
for people who so they don't have to
hear ads either
it's almost like you provided a space
for
like super fans almost because it's like
i know
are true fans maybe that's the way to
toward it but i love how
we have this platform you know about 6
000 true fans
and it's interesting when we are looking
for
some feedback from our audience from our
fans like that's the first place we go
because we know like they're going to
give us the most honest feedback in fact
you know some of the comments we get
it'll be you know some feedback hey you
know notice this or notice that and it's
like the one place we can go and we're
like oh
like they're not be this isn't out of
malice like this is out of like they
really care about us and they're trying
to provide us something where
i don't even look at the youtube
comments jessica looks at the youtube
comments there's like so many things
that you just said there that are i
think are like part of what we're trying
to accomplish with patreon
like the kind of troll-free space that
is
the the kind of living room version of
of
um social interaction versus in our
community
yes and and like the patron what we've
seen
in a patron base and a member base like
the the the call to pay wall call it
something else
that gate to take out your wallet and
put in a dollar to be a part of the
community
the people who are just stumbling by the
internet and yelling at other people for
being themselves
those people aren't going to take out a
dollar and
and join the community to leave a
negative zero
so like and and that goes to this
phenomenon
that basically you know humans will kind
of pay attention
to anything they'll just like they'll
pay attention to crap that's why the
internet is full of click bait and
garbage because
because it's it's an attention-based
medium right and
and and essentially tech companies have
figured out a way to equate
attention with revenue right right so
attention is a proxy with revenue this
classic attention economy stuff that
people been talking about for years
nothing new there
but in that world you basically create
an environment
where pastors buy can be
just as powerful have just as big of a
voice
like what what kind of system is that
for the arts that doesn't make any sense
i totally agree
um like it's much better to have a close
community of supportive people
who want to be a part of the process and
who have deep invested relationships
with the people that they're interacting
with
that's like what a tribe should be
that's like a more it's a more human
form of social interaction yeah
indeed ours is a listener driven show
ryan let's get into some of these
questions
here we have one from crystal on
facebook
crystal asks how do i best prepare
myself to make the jump
from working full-time for others to
working full-time as a small business
owner with
as much tranquility as possible and she
gives a couple examples of
emergency fund mentor support clear
objectives milestones exit strategy
you know jack it's interesting because
i think we quite often wait to make some
sort of leap until everything is perfect
and then we never leap as a result i'm
sure you've seen that oh god
i yeah um like my you know what i would
tell
lots of youtubers and advice that i that
i try to
live myself you know is like if you want
to be a youtuber be a youtuber
right now take out your phone make a
video
put it on youtube and learn something
from it yes and then adjust
afterwards and see what works in this
case it sounds to me like chris and
chris crystal crystal like is already
thinking
very clearly and strategically about
this even from the way the the question
is framed
it like exit strategy and kush like
crystal you're you got it like you're
thinking enough
yes and uh and and yeah i mean
at least for me the way i did that you
know before i was a
a kind of professional artist i suppose
i was doing corporate background music
for
uh you know i was like for hire as a
freelancer making music to pay the bills
making music to pay the bills
but not my i was they weren't my songs i
wasn't writing i was like
okay you need something that sounds like
linus and lucy great here you go
um and uh and and the way the way i did
what i thought about is
let me take a gig where i can get paid
but i can build my
skill set and my expertise on the thing
that i want to do for myself
and that way i'm spending hours and
hours and hours
honing my craft practicing in a way
exactly practicing for this path paid
the practice
yeah exactly you're getting paid to
practice yeah and then and then i
basically
started selling mp3s online started
making a few hundred you know bucks a
month and at some point it was enough
when i could make the transition
but it was only because i had spent
years honing my craft and getting paid
to practice
so before you started patreon you didn't
make sure that you had
a really good mentor support you had an
emergency fund you had clear objectives
milestones and an exit strategy you're
telling me you didn't do all those
things before
jumping into it the lack of thought i'm
serious here
sometimes i get questions because you
know whatever tech people are supposed
to be geniuses and strategic
that's not me i'm not one of those
people now i've learned a lot over the
last eight years but when we started
patreon
are you kidding me goals strategy
business plan right
zero you want me but you had a great
idea and you had a passion for it
and i i tell you what when ryan and i
first started the minimalist we were
both in the corporate world we had
simplified our lives and ryan came to me
and he's like hey
i think some people would find value in
what we're doing and i think ultimately
if a business will make money as long as
you're adding value quite often we try
to
make money as the objective that wasn't
what we went into it at
in fact i anticipated that by now i
would be a full-time novelist it just it
went the other way
and we've been writing non-fiction for a
decade and
and that's been great like it was it's
been a pivot for us in a way
but we realized like oh well people are
willing to support you whether it's
patreon or books or we do tours etc
they're willing to support you if and
only if they find value
if you do something that's clickbaity
that's why our podcast titles they're
one two or three words always there's
never some sort of elaborate
scheme to get you to click on our video
and maximize
the you know optimize the eyeballs
that are aggregated onto our services
what we're trying to do is add value
when people find value in it
they tend to support you in some way so
josh you said something that uh
you brushed over a little bit but i
think is really important about how we
simplified our lives so
you know when we left the corporate
world josh
laid himself off which is a great story
if you haven't heard it
we've written about it we'll have to
send it to you um and then i got
i got laid off but what we had done is
we had simplified our lives so much
that when we left these very high paying
jobs we were able to
survive so i guess i'm assuming i know
you had you said you had maxed out two
credit cards so it's not like you didn't
have
um no debt but i'm assuming it was kind
of the same for you where
maybe your life was simple enough to
where you didn't have to
i don't know keep doing these corporate
gigs and not able to take the risks
that's where a lot of people
are they're they're so tied down by debt
and all these anchors
that they're scared to take these risks
because their lives aren't so simple
yeah the the truth for me is i was
you know i've learned a lot in the last
six years
at eight years at patreon before then
i never was in the corporate world i i
like patreon literally is my first job
that i've ever had it's the first
company i've ever worked at
um so you know i
there was a there's a lot that i just i
wish i had
done what you're saying i wish i had
simplified i wish i had
streamlined i wish i had tight control
of my finances those are all things that
i kind of have figured out over the last
few years
um but in my 20s when i was a
you know young emerging artist trying to
like fix things and and figure things
out
i really didn't have a good
understanding of a lot of that stuff
um did you own a house i owned a house
okay i owned a house
and and i built a recording studio okay
um
and and we i mean we bought the house
and and the
land and everything off of our mp3 sales
from itunes sales from
from pompanos yeah incredible yeah i
mean we were we're
like making up you know we're making it
work we're like very early internet you
know 2008
kind of going viral i love this because
you didn't have this simplified life i
was assuming you were like just out of
college
so you didn't have like a ton on your
plate but it sounds like you did have a
decent amount on your plate
but you still were able to go for it it
wasn't like you're like okay well you
know i'm gonna make sure that
my house is paid off first before i
really go for this entrepreneurial thing
i'm gonna make sure
my credit cards are paid off before i do
anything it's you still had a lot on
your plate and one-fourth that's super
encouraging because again there's a lot
of people out there
they use these things you know like debt
as an excuse to not
try something different because trying
something different they think oh well
i won't be able to afford all these
anchors that i have yeah i actually
made the decision i wrote a blog post
about it at the time
i made the decision to not be prudent as
strange as that sounds i literally
yeah it was so so i'm i am
um you know
i'm i overthink things i i
really lay it out i'm i'm a planner i
like to plan i like to be
i like to like really lay it out i
i thought to myself i'm just gonna go
into artist
mode for this video i'm not going to lay
it out i'm not going to
build a budget i'm just going to have a
dream
and i'm going to do whatever it takes to
make this video
real and i and i had this sense that if
i
if i started editing myself
too much and started worrying too much
about the financial end of it
that it would compromise the work itself
without a doubt
yeah and so i decided to see what would
happen
it was like well let's try this path
forward yes
what happens if i i called it i think in
the blog post i called it burying my
prudence in the backyard and i'll go dig
it up in a few months like i'm not
saying goodbye forever
right i'm just like i'll just gonna bury
it for a while and i'm just gonna be
crazy for three months and it was a
conscious decision to kind of let all
those things go
and to just be crazy and i did i dug
myself into a hole right i like i got
into a little bit of a hole
but um i got out of it yeah and
everything was fine yeah
absolutely yeah hey ryan we've got a
question from meredith and austin i
think i'm going to save this for the
maximum episode
because it's a i think a robust answer
will be useful on this it's about
insurance and walking away from the
corporate world
and and not having insurance and how
that's terrifying and i i don't want to
skip that so podcast shawn
make sure we talk about that on the
maximal
uh crystal i'm gonna send you a copy of
our new book it's called love people use
things it comes out on july 13th uh i
think you'll find
some value in the relationship with
creativity chapter it's a relationship
book it's about the seven
essential relationships in our lives one
of those relationships is our
relationship with creativity
and quite often we think about
relationships about our relationship
with people
and that's one of the relationships
relationship with people but it often
starts with the relationship with stuff
all we have all these relationships that
kind of get in the way of our
relationship with people
and also our relationship with
creativity we're so distracted now
more than ever before that it's really
difficult to be creative in fact many of
the things we do when we
get online they ape the form of
productivity
or creativity but they're actually
stifling our creativity
in many ways we can we can browse
twitter all day
and get a little dopamine rush and it
almost fills that
creative void for the moment but it
ruins the thing that we're trying to
create
and so we're gonna send you a copy of
love people use things
if you like the podcast you'll like the
audiobook version of that we're actually
in the middle of recording it
right now or if you want the book book
or the ebook version we'll send those to
you as well ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it is time for our
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments too
937-202-4654
yes indeed now jack this is where ryan
and i and our guest
we do our best to answer questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response love it
but not really we monitor on a bit and
we we find something that's tweetable
podcast sean puts it in the show notes
so people can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media
oh by the way you can find all of our
minimal maxims in one place now
minimalmaxims.com ryan has a question
for us a question from adela
when do you know it's time to turn your
side hustle
into your full-time business i'm sure
there are a lot of people out there
afraid to take the leap
and they stay in their full-time jobs
instead well as i mentioned earlier
ryan and i we were still in the
corporate world and
we started the minimalists and there was
no revenue at all in fact we didn't ever
intend
to make any revenue from it that was not
the it wasn't until like i got laid off
you laid yourself off and we were like
oh man
maybe we should look at writing a book
or something yes yeah
so many people at that point because we
had added so much value and it was close
to a year into it we're like
hey you're the minimalist maybe you
should write a book about minimalism
we're like that's a great idea hey
what so we wrote our first book it's
called minimalism
and um yeah and that was over a decade
ago and so you know
it wasn't about like just simply taking
the leap right away
as jack alluded to earlier you can start
sort of practicing
and getting the skills that you need now
i had written for a decade
previous to laying myself off so i had
that skill
that i developed over time but i never
made a penny from it in fact the only
people who read my stuff
were agents who told me no repeatedly
but
once i got rid of the gatekeepers no
longer was i
beholden to a yes from someone else and
patreon has done the same thing in many
ways it's
who's saying yes now it's the people who
support the work in many ways
that's it and yeah i mean i yeah again i
think like
you know part of especially if that's
the kind of career that you want to make
for yourself if you want to make a
career where you're actually
online and building a following and
managing community and saying something
in the world and you're sort of a paid
communicator thinker writer author video
creator whatever it is
the first step i think is building that
audience it doesn't mean wait to build
your audience
build the audience like right now start
that like right now um
but just know that there's a difference
between audience building
and making money like those things don't
happen at the same time
building an audience takes a little time
and so it's good to start that i found
right away start the audience building
if you have something to say if you want
to be
heard say it you know start saying it
yeah yeah
well we often say there's good money
good businesses make money
great businesses make a difference and i
think that
in fact when ryan and i similar to you i
see a lot of parallels we didn't have a
business plan when we started this
we didn't have what we still don't have
a five-year plan or
it's just like we work on one major
project at a time whether it's one of
our netflix films or
it is a book or it is
a tour whatever it might be we work on
one major project at a time
usually one project a year even and then
everything else we do sort of
supplements that
the podcast the blog the email
newsletter social media
those aren't the primary drivers it's
whatever the main creative project is
then everything else is sort of
supplemental to that but it always comes
back to those two words for us
add value because you're right because
you've built an audi
anyone can build an audience if you do
something crazy enough just like a car
crash
if you go crash a car into 17 other cars
a bunch of people are going to
rubberneck and they're going to look and
say
oh yeah but they're not going to stick
around once the car crashes sort of
cleaned up
and so anyone can attract attention all
you have to do is something
something gratuitous but that doesn't
build trust
and what does build trust is the
continuous slow drip of adding value to
a few people ryan tells a story in our
latest film about
when uh we first started the
minimalists.com was december 2010
and 52 people visited our website in the
first month
and that sounds really unimpressive i
get it
but for me i had been writing for a
decade
and 52 people hadn't read what i and so
it was like 52 people saying yes
all of a sudden and 52 turns into 500 5
000 5 million over time because
and only because people start sharing it
with their friends family sisters
brothers mothers daughters
and and over time as the audience builds
and they're getting value from it
then their eagle is eager to support
what you're doing the opposite
could have happened ryan and i could
have said all right we're going to start
the minimalists and we're going to go on
tour and we're going to make a movie and
we're going to
and i think it none of it would have
gotten done it would have been so
overwhelming oh my gosh it's 2015.
it's five years later we we should have
had a movie and a podcast by now
yeah right right and so like what we did
is it was like well what is the step
in front of us right now exactly so i
just made a film about this duo called
rhett and link
they've been on youtube for you know
retlink okay i mean they have this
amazing show called good mythical
morning
they you know new episode every day plus
just so much
content they're incredible creators
but they said exactly the same thing
when they started rent link
two guys in a bedroom making stuff
together
now it's a hundred person company in
burbank with
office space and green screens and sound
stages
and full staff and production facilities
and like the whole thing
and when i was asking them you know what
i was trying to get i was like how did
you guys do this
you know that's like those the sort of
purpose of the doc was just
learning about them and i was like did
you want to run a company
and he he said exactly what you said
he's like no we just
we just took the next step forward at
every every day we took one more step
forward and then you need somebody to
help you do this and then
they're helping you for six months then
they need somebody to help them so you
bring in another person on and then the
team starts growing and then
the example you gave is and then your
parking lot is full and
somebody's got to worry about that
because i can't be worrying about the
parking lot right
and that's how they built mythical
entertainment it's just such a cool
story
one step at a time whatever the next
thing is just do that
we've worked really hard to grow
intentionally as opposed to
because in our culture there's this
demand for never-ending non-stop growth
in fact
publicly traded companies have a
fiduciary responsibility to grow
on behalf of their shareholders right
but for us
that's almost like a that's a tumor is
that kind of growth right just keeps
growing no matter what
and we wanted to avoid that sort of
growth but we did want to grow
in sort of an intentional way but also
we've done a few things like on patreon
we have two of our tiers that are capped
so
we have this vip tier it's 250 people
and people constantly ask us how do i
get
and it's like well that's it that's only
250. so the only way you can get in
there is when someone
leaves the tier which very rarely
happens we have the thousand true fans
here which is a tear on there
and it's also capped and so when we
realized like yeah more people can sign
up for these things
but we don't we've we've identified what
enough is
and that's another thing that we never
stop to think about early on
is like well what is enough because if
we don't know what enough
is then we're going to constantly be
discontented by the fact that we haven't
grown like someone else
and so if ryan and i started looking you
know what rhett and link started around
the same time as us and we don't have a
hundred employees
so i feel when i look at matt d'avella's
youtube channel yeah yeah
so matt directed both of our films you
know matt you've been on his on his show
and super talented and um he you know
when
he took off on youtube and if all of a
sudden it was like well we need to grow
i'm not happy unless we have matt
d'avella numbers right yeah i mean
and then matt's not happy until he has
you know kim kardashian number one
exactly and that is a fruitless pursuit
because uh
the pursuit of happiness is actually
what's making us discontent
in many ways i do have a um a pithy
answer i want to share
oh yeah this is the landing round
[Laughter]
is that what you guys meant by sound
bites yeah we've got a 10 minute
dialogue you know
podcast shawn makes it really pretty in
post i don't think he edits any of this
right now
all right so here's the here's my pithy
answer change occurs when the status quo
becomes unbearable yeah i think that
that's where ryan and i were people say
weren't you scared to leave your
corporate job
yeah i was but you know what was scarier
staying yeah
staying because i realized i was the
guys who i aspired to be like
and i was getting closer and closer i'd
worked my way up to middle management by
age 27
i managed 150 retail stores which sounds
crazy because it was
but as i got closer to these guys i want
to be the senior vp
of blah blah blah but then i met the
senior vp of blah blah blah and he was
miserable
on his second heart attack and third
marriage and i'm like well wait if i
work really hard for the next
15 years that will be me it's not that
he's a bad person
he followed a recipe and if i follow the
same recipe i'm going to bake the same
cake
yeah my pithy answer is this
playing it safe will keep you alive
embracing change will help you thrive
so you know adela is playing it safe
right now and
there's a seth godin essay i was trying
to find it but
i always do this where like i'll read
something profound of his
it gives me some really good insight and
then i can never find the the essay that
he really followed away in the steel
tree right
exactly so but he talked about and i'm
gonna do a bad phrase of pair
uh a bad job of paraphrasing this but he
talked about how when you take a leap
you want to minimize as much risk as
possible and when i was reading this uh
you know very short blog post that he
had i was thinking about like jumping
out of an airplane let's say that i'm
like you know what i really want to jump
out of an airplane i'm not going to do
that with nothing right i'm going to
think about okay what's the best way to
jump off an airplane a real minimalist
would do it with nothing right exactly
so
i uh i jumped out of an airplane with
nothing and survived because minimalism
tune into our patreon to find out how so
if you jump out of an airplane what do
you need you need uh you need
the skill set you need a parachute
um you know your first time jumping out
you need an instructor you might have to
go tandem they need an emergency pair
so there are there are ways to minimize
the risks of jumping out of an airplane
and then once you jump there's no
guarantee that just because you minimize
as many risks as possible that that
is gonna end okay probably is gonna end
a lot better than if you
uh didn't plan as well if you if i
jumped with nothing
right so i mean that's what i think
about when he when i was reading that
essay it's in
it's and it's not about having like a a
pair like a golden parachute when you
leave your corporate job it's just more
about
you have to take a leap eventually and
yes you want to you want to look at some
risks and like
cover the big risks but you're never
going to minimize
every single risk and at a certain point
you're going to have to jump but
but yeah do so uh do so with putting a
little thought in mind
but you know uh it doesn't you can't
cover everything i do want to talk to
you about debts when we get on the the
max website because i know a lot of
people have questions about
what's the appropriate amount of debt to
have when we move forward i'll just give
you the pity answer on that now is
having none is the most appropriate
because that's
then you're not tethered to to anything
right so it's always better
to have no debt than it is to have that
if you're if you're considering making a
l a life altering change now we got a
bunch more to talk about
i have two things for our added value
segment today
but first let's check out some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
hi
my name is hannah and i'm from la and i
wanted to leave a comment for listeners
based on your addiction episode my
husband and i have been
dealing with addiction issues in our
families and relationships for many
years and we've finally found an
approach that has aligned well
with minimalism and all the things we've
learned from
josh and ryan so there's a recovery
program called
smart recovery for addicts and loved
ones
as well as a book for loved ones called
beyond addiction
how science and kindness can help people
change
both encourage a real methodology
steeped in science
that allowed us to simplify these
really intimidating issues we wanted to
share what we found
in hopes that it will help other
minimalists simplify the
complexity of addiction issues in their
lives
hi my name's amanda from rebel stoke bc
canada and these tips are for jeremy
from episode 147
regarding his questions concerning
saving for his child's future
educational costs with an ex-partner
as a divorced mom myself with an
ex-partner who didn't initially see the
value in saving for our son's future
education
i would recommend the following number
one if possible try to have something
added to your separation agreement which
states exactly how much each parent is
to contribute
annually to an education savings fund
for your child
number two get creative start chatting
with your child now about different ways
to save money and work while in
university to make up for any shortfalls
for example things like becoming a paid
teacher's assistant resident advisor
campus bookstore rep etc you can also
start talking to them about finding jobs
that will pay for their living expenses
plus a little bit extra during their
university breaks
things like summer camps resorts and
cruise ships are all great options
in this way students can work during all
of their breaks not live at home during
their breaks
see the world and get paid to do it in
fact i personally was able to work
seasonally during my entire six years of
university where i earned four degrees
and pay off 35 000 in student loan debt
in just one year of working full-time on
cruise ships after i finish my last
degree
a great place to start your research is
youtube for example you can just youtube
or google how to work on a cruise ship
seasonally
and you'll come across just a ton of
info i want everyone to know there are
ways to finish a university
almost completely debt-free or debt-free
totally get paid to travel and see the
world
and build your resume at the same time i
hope this info helps and thanks guys for
everything you do
all right joe we got a bunch more
questions this thursday on patreon
that's the maximal episode
on the minimalist private podcast but
first real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalist
now jack this is our segment right here
right now we just talked about something
that's been going on with us
it's often an opportunity for us to
promote something that we've been doing
i just started this little
solo podcast but i did it only on
patreon and it's called
and it's only on the minimalist patreon
so you get it there's no charge for it
if you are a patron already
it's just part of our our patreon um
subscription
but it's called minimalism today and i
called up some people and just had
conversations and said what are you
struggling with
and it was neat because that that
platform i didn't have to make this
whole big public thing
but it was almost like trying it out my
guess is that that minimalism today will
actually turn into something bigger in
the future because i really enjoyed it i
learned a lot from it
but it was a platform for me to try that
out where i didn't have
you know i was able to sort of walk the
tightrope but i was holding on to the
edges
at first and it worked out really well
and i couldn't have done that without
patreon so thank you for that oh that's
amazing yeah so
you all can check that out uh
minimalism.today there's a free episode
up on our patreon
page right now you can listen to that
right now for our added value segment
this week i've got two added values
there's an instagram account i follow
ryan it's called visualize
value it's a different jack i think his
name is jack butcher
over on instagram we'll put a link to
this in the show notes anyway he sort of
captures simplicity in these
aggressively simple drawings they're
like infographics but
it's it's like if you took our entire
podcast
and just made it into one instagram post
in a way like
it conveys simplicity so well so if you
if you're looking for something to
follow on instagram that will actually
add value to your life and it's not just
something that you have to
feel obligated to double click then that
might be the account for you to follow
but then also i wanted to end the
episode today with the pamplemoose song
so um we we tend to play songs quite
often at the end of our
our podcast and you had an album come
out last year called worst of 2020.
and was that all covers uh no there were
a couple originals
okay in there too yeah we do we do
generally about
probably 30 originals and maybe 70
covers these days
well there's a cover you did a cover of
dreams which was was thrust into the
zeitgeist once again
last year because of uh i think the
guy's name was nathan
out in um out in idaho he was
skateboarding and he played that
the dream song right right it got big on
tick tock yeah yeah yeah it got really
big and
you did this this cover that well i love
when people do covers
that are true to the original song but
also utterly different
it comes from my jazz background so i
grew up as a jazz pianist and and when
you
you know jazz pianists are famous or
jazz musicians in general i think are
famous for like taking one element about
the song like the melody and ditching
everything else the harmony the tempo
the pacing the you know
so so that's kind of what we did is we
took like the melody and the lyrics
threw everything else out and just
reimagined it from the ground up awesome
well let's listen to dreams
by pamplemoose by the way we got a bunch
more surprise questions this week like
how do i get started as a small business
owner when i don't have any funds to
invest
what's a reasonable time frame to move
on
from relying on your employment income
to relying on self-employment income
what are the biggest mistakes people
make that prevent their small
business from being profitable plus
we're going to discuss a few secret
things that we're going to create
just for our patrons and a million more
other questions for jack conte you ready
i'm ready all right we're going to do it
here in a second if you want to hear all
that join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week visit
patreon.com the minimalist to subscribe
and get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast
app you can follow the minimalist on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist
you can follow jack jack conte on
instagram twitter at
all yep all right beautiful that's the
best place to follow him come to one of
our live podcast shows those are
starting up soon
visit the minimalist.com tour to find a
city near you if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
comment on this episode youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list
over at the minimalists.com you'll also
receive any new minimalist writings for
free
and if you leave here today with just
one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'd be fine
without it